-One of the characters,
who's fantastic
and is one of the professional
skateboarders in his first film,
his character's name --
and, obviously,
this is gonna get beeped
for broadcast --
is [bleep]
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And can you explain --
-F-S.
-Yes.
Can you explain how he --
It's such a wonderful detail
as to why that's his nickname.
-Because anytime
he sees something he likes,
he yells out, "[Bleep]
That was dope."
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good --
You actually -- You did work
at a skateboard shop
when you were young?
-I spent a lot of time at a shop
called Hot Rod in West L.A.,
which is now, I think,
a barbershop,
and for some reason,
they kept the name.
[ Laughter ]
And so, it sucks,
because so many kids
grew up going there
and, like, spending their youth
at this place,
and now it's a barbershop,
and it's weird.
So, but, yeah.
I mean, it was a great place.
I learned a lot of amazing
and terrible lessons,
and I found people
that I really related to,
and, honestly,
it gave me this lens
that I kind of think
I really do see life through,
like a certain taste,
a certain --
You know, there was a magazine
called "Big Brother"
that was such a subversive
sense of humor, you know?
That "Jackass" came out of.
And, you know, just taste
in music, in hip-hop and punk,
and sort of the way
that young people
dealt with authority
was very different
in this group of gentlemen than
it was in other parts of life.
And for whatever reason,
it spoke to me,
and I'm no ambassador
for skateboarding.
I'm not an authority on it.
But I'm a nerd who loves it
and wanted
to see it honored onscreen.
-You also wrote a magazine
that is a companion,
I guess, to the film.
-Definitely.
-And this is --
you interviewed 12 people
that you love and respect
about being that age, yeah?
-Yeah, it's basically
a companion piece to the movie,
a magazine I made with A24,
called "Inner Children."
And the movie, at its core,
is about this kid who's lonely,
and he finds
his group of people.
Really,
it's about self-acceptance.
So, basically, his currency
is getting the [bleep]
kicked out of him
and taking abuse
and taking hits,
whether it's on a skateboard,
at home, to himself.
And, you know,
I don't want to give it away,
but the journey
is self-acceptance
and self-love, essentially.
And so I wrote this magazine
because I believe
everybody has
this snapshot of themselves.
And it's a snapshot
that they kind of
want to hide from the world.
And so mine was, like,
being this, like, 14-year-old,
overweight kid, kind of
feeling ugly to the world,
wanting to fit in with
this group of skateboarders,
and I kind of feel like,
even if that's not yours,
that every person has one
of these they can relate to.
So, I interviewed
a lot of my heroes --
my sister, Beanie Feldstein,
from "Lady Bird"
and "Hello, Dolly!"
DJ Premier, Behati Prinsloo,
Edie Falco,
Kim Gordon from Sonic Youth,
Mark Gonzalez, Michael Cera,
Na-kel Smith, Q-Tip,
Raymond Pettibon, a lot of
my favorite artists and people,
and it was so meaningful
to find out
that peoples
are completely different,
but they hurt just as much.
-Sure.
-And so it was just a nice
kind of liberating way
to spend these last few years
figuring out
who I am as a person,
how do you love yourself,
and how do you be yourself
and be the artist that you are
without apologizing for it.
And what came out
was this magazine and "Mid90s,"
and I hope
you enjoy both of them.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You have long been an artist --
You've long been an artist
that people have been
inspired by your work.
I did not realize
the level of inspiration.
You've posted
a few of these on Instagram.
People have gotten
Jonah Hill tattoos.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And now, I think,
when I say that,
you're picturing something,
and it's a lot more intense
than even what
you're picturing.
So this is what somebody did.
-Yeah, that's --
[ Audience groans ]
-I think that's
the perfect comment to write,
which you just wrote, "Okay."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But how about this gentleman
that wants to go through life
with that on his --
[ Audience groans ]
-Again, I was very clever.
I wrote, "Okay."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I think that would be
what you would say
if somebody came up to you,
was like,
"Jonah, I want to show you
something really cool."
-I mean it's a little better
that they're characters
as opposed to me just, like,
chilling.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-And it's -- yeah.
I really don't know how to feel,
to be honest with you.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I feel honored and weird,
and I hope
you enjoy my face forever.
[ Laughter ]
You know what?
For the first time in my life,
I enjoy having
my face on me forever,
so I think you can have --
-There you go, yeah.
Give it up.
Spread the wealth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Last but not least,
you are gonna host --
Next week, you're hosting "SNL"
for the fifth time.
-Yeah.
-That is fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was there your first time.
-Yes, you were.
-And a character of yours
that still, to this day,
is one of my favorite things
that I ever was lucky enough
to work on.
You played Adam Grossman,
who is a 6-year-old.
There he is with his dad,
Bill Hader, at a Benihana,
and he's --
-Yeah, and you --
And Bill and I got to write
the first one of those
we did together.
-Yeah, he was just a very
precocious 6-year-old
who sounded like
a very old Jewish man.
-Yeah. So, essentially,
Hader was telling us
a story about --
in his hometown,
he went to Benihana,
and he saw a kid,
but he didn't know if
it was like a 40-year-old man
or a 6-year-old kid, because
he had a velour tracksuit on,
and when the chef did --
I'm getting so many laughs
off Bill's bit.
But when the chef did the trick,
the kid just went --
[ Clapping ]
[ Laughter ]
And so, I think Bill
started doing him
as a Mafia, like,
Tony Soprano guy.
And you were there!
And then, I started doing him
as, like, a Catskills --
-Yeah, he was very Catskill.
-Like super-hacky Catskills.
And then you, Bill, and I
stayed up all night writing it,
and we were laughing.
-It was great.
-It was one of the joyous
memories of my life.
It was a great time.
-And the best moment of it
was his catchphrase
if he had one was, "I'm 6."
-I think
he would definitely have --
say he had a catchphrase,
'cause he shouted it out.
-But the genius
that you added to it was,
he didn't quite hold up
his six fingers
with the confidence
that he said "I'm 6."
Can you give us a little of
the Adam Grossman fingers?
-Yeah, 'cause, little kids,
they like --
they, like, hold up their hands.
[ Laughter ]
Or, like, they --
They, like, don't do it right.
-It was my favorite detail
of the character.
I'm so happy
to see you back on the show.
And, man, it is great
to have you here, as well.
Congrats on the movie.
Jonah Hill, everybody.